so our next presenter is Roger
Schoenfeld who many of you may know as a
friend and colleague to many of us here
today and leads the research efforts at
Ithaca SNR Ithaca SNR also a friend I
think to academia in its explorations of
the intersect between academia the wider
world and trends that happen in higher
education Roger has served not only at
Ithaca but as on the NSF Blue Ribbon
task force for sustainable digital
preservation and access and on the
Western Regional Support trust Advisory
Committee he's opponent has published
many works but probably best known for
his JSTOR a history from mine from 2003
actually focusing on the development of
sustainable not-for-profit business
model for the digitization and
preservation of scholarly texts today
Roger is going to tease us a little bit
with highlights from two recent studies
that did a little bit into the research
behaviors and the teaching learning
behaviors of scholars in two different
disciplines please join me in welcoming
our friends
hi thanks thanks everyone thanks Carolyn
I'm I'm going to try to keep reflect in
a few ways on some of the things that
Malcolm was just saying just to get
started because I think there's actually
a really lovely transition that I don't
think we exactly planned but the
organizers should be commended for one
way or the other which is which is that
which is really that you've heard a lot
about the ways that I I think based on
some of our work we would agree at the
guess nor would agree that some of the
ways some of the major trends that are
impacting on the instructional mission
of the university and in parallel what
I'm going to spend some time talking
about is some of the trends that are
impacting on the research mission of the
university and the the research side of
faculty members we're let me let me just
kind of let me just kind of dive into to
what I'm going to try to do today I'll
say just a few words about what what we
are broadly trying to do in terms of
understanding how the research practices
of academics are changing and why we're
doing that and then I'll share findings
from two recent studies that have been
completed in December and February
respectively on history and chemistry
and then I hope I hope I'll have a
little bit of time for for questions and
discussion but at least to sort of tease
you with some of the the ideas that we
think are are coming out of the out of
this set of projects this is this is for
just to say these are the organizations
that are part of Ithaca Ithaca SNR is
the service that I'm associated with in
portico and JSTOR are also part of the
Ithaca organization the the what we're
trying to essentially figure out how
best to do is to facilitate scholarship
in an environment of change and for many
universities certainly for research
universities the facilitation of
scholarship is at the heart of the
mission of those enterprises not to
exclude other missions but it's one of
the ones that's at the heart and and
many people would say that scholarly
practices have been in flux since the
very beginning of scholarship I think no
with that but I can demonstrate that
scholarly practices have been influx for
the last ten or fifteen years and I
think I think we we're all familiar with
some of the essential drivers of change
the way that that new technologies that
the shift to the network that
digitization that different kinds of
opportunities for collaboration that
changes in funding models in some cases
and many many other factors are
reshaping the ways that scholars on a
day-to-day basis do their work and our
faculty survey has been tracking those
trends since since 2000 and since the
theme of the day today is trending I'd
like to just say that we've found a
number of really important trends over
the last decade and more and when our
newest cycle of the faculty survey comes
out and just about a week and a half
from now I think that one of the things
that we're going to find is that in some
cases trend lines are inexorable
and that's sometimes an characteristic
of technologically driven change but
sometimes it's the it's the quote from
from Warhol that we have to I'm sorry I
didn't write down the quote but I did
take a picture of it but I don't have it
in front of men because we have to we
actually have to read the responses or
the initiatives that whether it's
libraries or instructional technologists
but any number of other kinds of support
services take on it could be that in
some cases trend lines are not
inexorable and that there are
opportunities to impact things and so
there's both of those kinds of trends
and I want to be really mindful that
that we're seeing both of those kinds of
things and and also shamelessly pleased
the faculty survey will be out in a week
and a half and I hope you'll take a look
at it when it comes out but um but but I
think the essential point that I want to
try to dry out here is is that is this
idea of of what Malcolm is saying about
rapid prototyping and smart failure and
Design Thinking and towards the end of
your presentation is is is is a
challenge I think an opportunity to for
libraries in particular
other research support service providers
as well to try to meet the changing
needs of researchers and recognize not
just the things that the library for
example would like researchers to be
doing but to recognize that in fact the
ways that researchers are changing can
be at the heart of that kind of design
thinking and that's that's essentially
what what this set of projects are are
all about so um these are a series of
scholar centric which means that we're
not as we're not paying as much
attention to what would the library like
to do as we're paying attention to what
do the scholars say they are doing and
indicate there they need a scholar
centric field specific approach so
that's discipline specific where in some
cases could be interdisciplinary field
specific approach which which we think
alongside many other inputs and one of
them is how's the university changing at
a broad strategic level and I think
Malcolm gave us a lot of really
compelling arguments about how some of
those broader institutional strategic
changes are happening so I think we have
to read those two factors together can
can be used to help libraries develop
new services so that's that's the
hypothesis that my colleagues and I had
going into this set of projects we
started the project opportunistically as
I said we finished the history and
chemistry project carol-anne is is
delighted I hope it's fair to put words
in your mouth that we're doing art
history next and and that's that's
underway and we hope to do a whole
series of discipline specific field
specific projects that over the course
of time will we'll be able to synthesize
across them and give a sense of how of
how broadly speaking scholars practices
and needs are changing and what that
means for the role of a library going
forward and the services and staffing
and the strategy of the academic library
at least on the research support side
and and and so that's anywhere so that's
what we're that's what we're up to so um
let me let me share some of the sort of
high level findings from both the
history and chemistry reports these are
both available on our web
sigh I I never know whether to give the
incredibly long URL that I feel like no
one can possibly write down or the
really short one that doesn't make any
sense you got the ladder but but anyway
you can just go to SRA if the cat at
work and it's easy to find the reports
this is focused on US academic
historians and was funded by the neh and
I'll just just kind of start by trying
to capture what who are historians is
users and archives and libraries right
if you are a library or on archive in
this room historians are among your
biggest fans right they are dedicated
users of all types of library materials
which is to say you know books and
journals and primary sources and and and
and all sorts of multimedia and so forth
and the most valued library service that
we found from the qualitative interviews
and and Institute meetings that we had
with faculty members in in this project
the most valued service is interlibrary
loan most valued service to the library
provides is interlibrary loan now now
there as we move to a more digital
environment just to say interlibrary
loan is a little next so I appreciate
the applause but just just to say that
this is you wouldn't want to rest on the
interlibrary loan laurels here and
that's I mean there's a there's there's
some really challenging dynamics as
those of you who are focusing on digital
collections and how they get shared
across campuses are you know there's
some really vexed dynamics that in our
report we try to point out but that is a
valued service now archives and special
collections are and this is by contrast
or vital to historians research okay so
that's I'm giving you you know 8.0 and
then I'm giving you 11-point OH archives
and special collections are vital and
historians develop close relationships
not with subject specialists in general
in the library but with archivists who
have deep expertise in there in
particular collections and subfields and
that's that's a distinction so a couple
of the couple of the major takeaways
from the report Google is the first port
of call we heard this again and again
and again
and again and this is google books in
particular Google's discovery services
as well it the Google Books is of
singular importance and that's
distinguished as against some of the
other major sources some of which major
academic libraries participate in of
digitized book content Google Books is
of singular importance and it's it's
used in really interesting ways actually
it's used in conjunction with reading a
book someone might have a book in front
of them and be going to Google Books to
instead of going to the index to be
searching searching the book that they
have right in front of them or we're
using it as a discovery service where
then they want to go get the print book
out of their academic library or
purchase it or whatnot so there are some
some really interesting use cases for
Google books that are complementary with
the way that that traditional reading
and access methods happen but this is of
singular importance and not to be not to
be underestimated something else that's
an amazing finding to me is that
historians are so pleased with all that
they can discover today but it's
actually it's actually producing more
and more anxiety and so the more that
you can discover the you know your your
searches during your research process
produce instead of instead of 20 things
you could look at could produce hundreds
or thousands of things that you could
look at and and there's anxiety about
did I find in that in that heap did I
find all of the things everything now I
can imagine comprehensiveness I can
imagine finding everything but did I and
they don't know and so that's that's a
question not about finding a lot of
things that are relevant to to to a
project but finding every single thing
and that's a very different kind of
discovery service that no one has
figured out how to develop at least in a
digital environment that I think is was
one of the one of the things we heard
quite a bit from historian the I don't
even know if anyone still has digital
cameras or everyone is just using their
smartphones but but I couldn't put a
picture of a smartphone up because
because you wouldn't understand that I
was trying to point to the to the the
image capture notion the the digital
camera is chain changing the way that
historians use
archives and and in particular they are
not doing as much analysis in the
archives as they once they're so they
are flipping through much more content
than they ever could before taking the
image and then the analysis the reading
and analysis and and thinking about what
does this what does this mean is
happening is happening in their home
office six months later it's displaced
in time and space as one of our advisory
board members said it more eloquently
than then I certainly could have and the
and and so and so this is opening up all
sorts of I think opportunities but also
challenges for the way that archivists
provide their services right so these
archivists were tremendously value are
you know there's no opportunity now for
us there's less and less opportunity now
for a scholar for historian to repoint
his or her project in mid course so you
know you can't say oh that letter I
looked at this morning was really
interesting so I think I'll get a
different record group that I was
looking at earlier because that takes me
in a slightly different direction the
I don't know if that's exactly
serendipity but that that that kind of
experience isn't happening as much so it
puts more of a burden on being able to
discover as much as you possibly can
before you've even gotten to the
archives to figure out exactly what do I
want to snap photos up so there are some
interesting dynamics there around you
know how does discovery happen and how
does analysis happen when can I consult
that research archivist or I want to
talk to I may not want to talk to them
face-to-face anymore I may need to talk
to them for months later when I'm 3,000
miles away so how do those kinds of you
know are we managing those kinds of
services and all those digital images by
the way could be really really useful
for discovery purposes couldn't they I
mean that's the full text of the
collections if they could somehow be
digitized and made more broadly
available so there's a whole lot of
really interesting things going on with
which digital image capture that's just
not less is being done with them than
could be certainly now this is this is a
picture from one of the most digitally
sophisticated digital
minused historians that we spoke to in
the course of our research and this is
how he wrote his book he had all of his
um all of his notes on a database of
some sort and you know he had all these
digital files and he was doing actually
computational a computational method was
in the heart of this and when he wanted
to write his book and gain intellectual
control of all of these disparate pieces
and organized them into an authored
narrative he printed them all out on
index cards or whoever wrote them out on
index cards in some cases and each of
these boxes is a chapter and each of
those little tabs is a section heading
and this is the best way he could come
up with to gain intellectual control
over his material and organize his
monograph and if that is not an
opportunity to rethink services I don't
really know what is I mean this I do in
the one hand maybe this is as good as it
gets maybe you know this maybe this is
the optimal technology for organizing
one's thoughts into a long narrative
okay so one of the things that really
came out is graduate student training is
not working well in a lot of his history
field in particular in terms of how
graduate students learn about research
methods and practices so that picture
before that that is how most students
are being taught how to write a book now
maybe again maybe that's the best way to
write the book and maybe that's how they
should be taught but but in fact what's
really happening is that they're not
really being taught it at all they're
just kind of learning by osmosis because
there aren't as many methods courses as
we understand they're once worth and
there certainly aren't courses in the
mechanics of how to do one's research
the research practices that I've been
referring to over the over the past 10
minutes or so so this is any number of
different service models that this might
suggest I'll just I'll just bank through
these really quickly I want to point out
that we we've largely tried not to focus
these in this presentation anyway I've
tried not to focus these around
what should the library do what should
the archives do there are services here
that are up for grabs if the library
wants to want to try to offer some of
these services maybe it could if the
American Historical Association wanted
to offer some of these services it
possibly could and I think that what
we're seeing is that when we take a
scholar centric perspective and you'll
see this again with the chemists it's
not always clear who owns what
responsibility it's not bounded by
traditional organizational models or in
structures so so some of these things
are maybe a little more straightforward
describing and digitizing collections
people who have collections probably are
principally responsible for those kinds
of things but how to make them
discoverable in standard research
processes when I'll remind you google
books is the first point port of call
how to do that is not clear who's going
to be responsible for that of what kind
of collaboration might make that
possible we I at the very beginning
mentioned that the expertise of
archivists is highly valued but the but
of course they don't operate on an
instant
so levels so if you are running the
Columbia University Libraries for
example and you want to provide support
for the historians on your campus how do
they work with how does a liaison
librarian and I don't I don't mean to
sing a lot of Colombians I don't even
know if we spoke to anyone at Columbia
for this project but you know how do you
how do you how do you provide that set
of expertise to the folks on your campus
and is there some kind of liaison model
or collaboration model is that one of
the directions that to pool and similar
kinds of collaborations open up I think
there's some really interesting
questions about how the deep deep
expertise is provisioned with respect to
cameras I don't think I mentioned this
but some at least one archive that we
came across charges a fee for bringing
your digital camera and taking photos in
the archive and actually charges a per
image feet to you and I understand why
they're looking to replace a revenue
source but you know the reality is that
that there's so much more that that
libraries could be doing to facilitate
the archives could be doing to
facilitate the use of digital cameras in
the archives and that's everything from
what do I do with all those images once
I've taken them I've got 5,000 images I
mean you guys know about organizing
large collections of of digital
materials and just how challenging that
is without good metadata and in some
cases anyway you actually have good
metadata about these collections so
there's some really interesting
questions about how you could really
really really facilitate the use of
digital camp digital cameras well
another thing that has become
increasingly clear to me not just in
terms of history but looking across
multiple fields is that citation
management or is is I mean I think
citation management strong way to even
think about what people are doing
anymore I don't
I think it's spilling over into research
notes management as I've mentioned here
organizing personal collections it's
actually project management right what's
the boundary between those boxes full of
index cards and citation management
services and why are we thinking about
all of those things as a single use case
of faculty members working with
materials so I think there's some really
interesting opportunities
someone should be thinking about here
and then finally our colleagues at the
aah a at the American Historical
Association really jumped quite a bit on
the need for different kinds of graduate
student training in particular in
research practices and research methods
and I doubt that this is a an issue
specific to the field of history but but
it certainly does obtain for the field
of history on a national on a national
level so that's a big mouthful but
that's some of the things that when you
start talking to historians about what
are you doing and what could help you do
your work matter that's some of the
things that that that come come to the
fore now the chemistry project you
couldn't imagine a more different feel
from history to chemistry in certain
ways the chemistry project is focused on
UK academic chemists so I just want to
be clear that there are some
idiosyncrasies here that are unique to
British funding models that some people
here won't won't find too relevant I'll
try to highlight those where I see them
and point out that there are others that
I think are largely transferable this
was funded by the JISC in the UK now
chemists as library users are in a
totally different place than historians
UK chemists anyway are totally satisfied
with their library collections they more
or less get access to what they want and
other than that they don't really have
much contact with their libraries and I
don't know if we asked it exactly but it
wasn't clear that they were craving more
access it were more contact with their
librarians became general now the
physical library is where it exists is
increasingly viewed as a space for
undergraduates it's not a space for
scholars I think that's probably
happening in science libraries in the US
as well to a fairly significant tree as
well and and so again certainly in the
UK the dynamic that has emerged is well
we don't really have a lot of services
to provide to chemists other than
collections so we probably can't even
devote a full time person to be the
liaison or subject specialist to the
chemistry department so you can see it's
kind of a spiral in that in that in that
sense so there aren't new services being
developed there aren't there isn't more
contact being asked for and so the
library and in
in the language of our faculty survey
the library is pretty much a buyer of
collections it's pretty much a
purchasing agent that's not a bad thing
but that's a that's a particular
particular role now that's not to say
that chemists don't have all kinds of
needs I mean chemists are craving
support for their research so what are
some of those what are some of the
things that we learn that might be
salient first of all thinking of
chemists as standalone researchers in
the way that we often think about
historians totally doesn't make any
sense many of you know that many science
fields organize their work especially
laboratory scientists organize their
work around laboratory groups and that
can have undergraduate students and
graduate students and postdocs and and
other kinds of collaborators and so how
do you think about service provision at
that at that organizational level rather
than at the level of dr. Jones and and
you know undergraduate students Smith
and so forth I haven't seen any
outstanding models for that and I'd be
really interested in being any pointers
to how to how to think about that as the
organizing unit of service provision
chemists have a ton of trouble or I
don't know if I'll call it trouble from
the perspective of people who think that
data should be well organized chemists
have a ton of trouble managing the data
in their in their laboratories things
are associated with one instrument
another instrument they live on this
hard drive because it this instrument
has a hard drive and they live on this
drop box because they put it on drop box
it lives here at lives there at lives
everywhere this is not a craving for
preservation I want to be very clear we
didn't talk to chemists who said to us
help me preserve my data for the long
term that wasn't the service they were
looking for they are looking for help
managing their data organizing their
data I don't know if they know the word
curating their data they want help they
would benefit from help putting all
their data in the same place keeping
track of it making sense of it ensuring
that the disk doesn't fail and so forth
that's not data preservation and it's in
the middle of the research process it's
not at the
of the research process so I think that
challenge is at least some of the data
preservation models in at least in US
academic libraries to a very significant
degree keeping up with the literature
current awareness is the discovery
challenge for it for chemists not not
comprehensiveness they have they have
this explosion of materials that are
coming into them they can subscribe to
table of contents alerts for seemingly
thousands of different journals and then
they never read any of them when they
come into their inboxes and so how do
you keep up with those couple of things
that really matter to you this month or
how does your let's put in a different
way how does your laboratory research
group keep up with the couple of things
that matter to you each month and maybe
to that kind of penumbra of other things
that are really really important and
significant in adjacent fields or
elsewhere in the field that you would
net that cert if you like that
serendipity of I should be reading that
because people people like me should be
reading that they really need new ways
to sift through the published literature
now this is this is a case where I think
we may have some distinctions against
the US and the UK but I think we should
still not just allied over it public
funding for chemistry lab in the UK is
increasingly tied to the impact of one
scholarship can you demonstrate the
impact of the various chemistry labs in
your in your university and based on
that you'll get research funding or less
research funding so dissemination and
supporting the strategic dissemination
of scholarship to maximise its impact
has a direct correlation with whether
those chemists will get funded in the
next funding cycle so gosh that would be
an amazing opportunity to think about a
dissemination support service now I
don't know if this matters quite as much
in the US but imagine if you could do
something that made your scientists more
impactful in their in their work that
note I'm not saying more open and and
maybe open is the solution to it I'm
saying more impactful because that's the
metric that's being measured
if if you could say to chemists I can
help you be more impactful and therefore
you will get more funding that would be
a really powerful service that that at
least in the UK would matter quite a bit
and I kind of suspect it could matter in
the US but maybe not quite as directly
so the three sets of service
recommendations that we that that came
out of the chemistry project and these
are even less tied to the library and
for the librarians here today you may
say I don't see my library here too much
at all or maybe you do I'm going to sit
in that actually so for discovery we
chemists would love services that will I
guess I kind of mentioned this before
that will create customizable and
efficient alerting services that speak
to the compound that they're working on
or the thing they've been trying to
figure out how to measure and then
restore serendipity to their work and oh
I didn't mention this before the review
article is so important to chemistry
it's it's almost like them it's not
quite the book review of history of
history but it's it's it's an incredibly
important discovery tool and entree into
the literature it's something that PhD
students often write as part of their as
part of their doctoral training so write
a review article of the thing that
you're working on and then that that can
be used now this is actually I mean you
know from a from a discovery perspective
it's a bibliography or it's a it's a
it's a curated it could be rethought
into into something that could integrate
into the kinds of discoveries services
that libraries publishers associations
are working on and and the review
article I think is one of the one of the
opportunities to is one of the special
opportunities to rethink discovery at
least for at least for chemists now on
the research management side note I'm
not focusing just on data here and the
reason why I'm not focusing just on data
data is a subset of research management
this is we were a little shy in the
or about digging into laboratory
management because we mean that we felt
that that was a little outside of our
purview but the reality is that the the
p i-- at the lab the the scholar who
leads the lab really needs a whole
plethora of different services and
infrastructure and system to run his or
her laboratory group more effectively
and that's everything from managing
hazardous materials to to you know
research data and so on and so forth
some of those things you might imagine
being within the purview of the library
some of these things you might say are
well outside the purview of the library
but the way that the library might hope
to play a really useful role in the
process of the chemistry scholar is to
figure out a way how to get integrated
into all of those things and and I guess
this strikes me as one one really great
example of where the boundaries between
you know oh well we're the library so
we're going to do this if you want to
support chemists that's just not going
to work there's gonna have to be all
kinds of collaborations with different
kinds of service providers to get into
the chemistry laboratory in a way that
makes sense to the chemist and not in a
way that makes sense to the librarian
and that's that's a key a key dynamic
that that I personally think his is is a
probably a barrier really to to engaging
really deeply with the sciences and and
if extent that research libraries want
to be more and more and more than the
purchasing agent I think is a barrier
that needs to be overcome and then
finally I mentioned before some of the
research dissemination activities that
that we saw chemists really benefiting
from in terms of in terms of the kinds
of of impact that they're trying to that
they're trying to maximize so those are
two really different disciplines and and
and I think that I think that you can
see at the very beginning of you know
some of those services may be very
deeply discipline specific some of them
may be more evocative of what humanists
need and what
to seed and you know we're really
looking forward as we do more of these
projects to starting to see well how
much of of this is generalizable how
much of this is very discipline specific
to the extent that something is
generalizable it might be something that
can there might be services that can be
offered at the campus level very easily
to extend the service requirements are
deeply discipline specific or even
subfield specific I think that's even
going to challenge whether they can be
offered
strictly speaking at the campus level or
whether again services like like to cool
and even broader collaborations like
that maybe a more significant locus of
activity going forward
so I thought I would just leave leave
leave us with a couple of questions just
just to kind of spark some discussion
and I'll be happy to answer any if
there's time be happy to answer any
question or have discussion about any of
these issues but you know I think that
this question about expertise to
historians is really vexing and and at
least it's vexing for me when I think of
a subject specialist as someone who has
a research support role I think the
question of whether there are ways that
beyond collections libraries would like
to and can effectively support chemists
is a really interesting question and
cuts at the very heart of for me looking
at our faculty survey where we have
other disciplines available to us for
analysis what is the library strategy
for engaging with scientists as
researchers there aren't tons and tons
of best practices available to us here
at this point I think I think it's fair
to say now discovery and research
management were actually two services
that that emerged for both historians
and chemists but in very different ways
right
chemists want current awareness
historians want comprehensiveness and to
have primary sources available to them
for discovery and so forth so whether
whether they're commonalities or
differences I think is a really
interesting is there a common set of
discovery services is that single search
box that many libraries are trying to
put on their homepage is that is that
going to meet researchers needs and if
not what is that what does that mean
research left management is
interesting because there are issues at
the laboratory group level for analysts
but at the individual project individual
researcher level for historians that I
think I think in that case I feel more
confident saying there's probably very
different tools and systems that are
needed and then I'm wondering if anyone
sees any implications for library
organizational design or strategy or
services that are emerging from from
this set of projects because as we build
out this program overall that's really
what we hope to be able to offer to the
community so let me let me stop and I'm
really eager for any questions or
discussion one other side that I can see
with this and it also does tails in with
Matthews presentation earlier is the
notion of undergraduate research
especially as it's situated in a
classroom and in learning management
systems and I can see there's a lot
there are classes where the purpose of
the class is guiding students through a
scholarly publishing process and they're
creating something that's meant for
public consumption and I think that the
I could I see a role for libraries in
helping the students through this
undergraduate through this process like
helping them with style and citation and
at our library we've actually done that
where are where we've set up like
scholarly journals for students and it
actually becomes part of the learning
process yeah and I think I think that's
I think that and in many other fields
probably less so history but in some of
the other undergraduate humanities
fields I think there is probably a
little more grand for that and and I
think that in some of our future
projects we may get into that a little
more but we didn't we really excluded
undergraduate research from from these
two projects to a great degree except
the extent that an undergraduate student
works in a chemistry lab which certainly
does happen occasionally Roger these
studies are extremely useful and
compelling and I think as you study more
and more of the disciplines we're going
to see some of these patterns and
organizational design questions
beginning to fall into place I observe
across disciplines a real need for the
discovery services that you've outlined
not unique to chemists or scientists but
across the disciplines particularly in
three areas one is for peripheral
book-related littered literature that
people don't normally look at and need
to be aware of
second is newly newly opened or
published digital collections of scanned
materials from around the world that
people may not be aware of and third is
great literature stuff that does not
normally enter the mainstream publishing
mainstream but can be very valuable and
is increasingly defining of the ways
scholars communicate and so I've seen
the discovery service
as relevant across disciplines and
really touching all those three streams
of information I think that's I think
that's that's that certainly emerged
from us with the history project that
one of the one of the real challenges
that that exists is that we to Peaks to
even to the extent that those things are
described or cataloged they're often not
accessible through the services that
libraries are promoting as discovery
services and so now that's not a problem
that any individual library can perhaps
solve on its own but if there's a
community problem that that's that's
really problematic that I hope we'll see
addressed over time one commonality we
might want to think about is two roles
that we play a woman we're very good at
and only need to get better at the first
one is being ending an ingredients
supplier and we seem to do that very
well as far as delivering the content
that the scholars won and in the Ithaca
research has demonstrated in the past
maybe the next study that's coming out
soon will confirm that we are looked at
as the ingredients supplier where we
might want to move and I see some
commonalities there from what you've
told us to be a solutions provider maybe
that's the role that we need to get out
there okay what are you having trouble
with what kind of what kind of support
you need and be better at constructing
solutions and I think that's a common
thing I heard both you and Malcolm say
to be more adept at design thinking and
that's what designers essentially do
they they try to figure out what
problems people are having and what are
elegant solutions to those problems so
we can maybe just get it down to two
things move from ingredients supplier to
solutions provider we might have a more
a stronger future in our education I I
think that's that's one of the that's
one of the motivating principles that
goes into this program of research and I
hope I hope that that this offers an
evidence base that can can be useful to
individual libraries and groups of them
to in thinking about about solutions
certainly one of the one of the
underlying concerns is as as we see
strategic change in the way that
collections are provided and libraries
have been at the forefront to try to
impact the way that collections are
provided that fire role that that
purchasing agent role many librarians
hope will fall away over time and so if
if the library is to have a vital future
in that kind of in that kind of
environment if in fact that is the
environment we're moving towards then
the solutions become perhaps the the
direction to take and this is just for
researchers and of course and of course
you know if if there was broader
strategic change in universities where
research and teaching is is less tightly
bundled together I think I think you
know we've heard some talk about that
and so forth you know there's also a
whole other set of directions that
libraries are taking in supporting
undergraduate studies and research and
so forth and it the gentleman with the
first question you asked about a little
bit about that I think that's a getting
that balance right is really is one of
the things that that I imagine many
librarians as they are thinking about
their their future and their role would
be dropping I feel that you're right
general got access but before you can
talk a whole lot about access you have
to talk about preservation and numerous
studies have shown that these
researchers chemists for example they
have the materials stored they want to
keep it for seven years to forever and
it's on their laptop or in their not
institutions here's an opportunity for
libraries to step up and start providing
preservation for lab notebooks datasets
also in conjunction
with federally mandated data plans etc I
think we may be moving in libraries from
away from the published literature so
much to locally generated digital or
digital information that we're reserving
any metadata to with their graduate
students and providing access otherwise
there's a whole realm of locally
generated information that's at risk and
could be lost ranging from research
undergraduate of projects etc and so
really I see the library continuing its
traditional role just with a different
format looking with born digital locally
on campus as opposed to so much as
published
yeah you know I'm reluctant to
generalize on on that particular point
for Italy in terms of generalize across
the sciences because I recognize that in
particular in biomedical sciences there
all sorts of different kinds of ethical
rules and mandates and so forth that
that that may be important but but I can
say that the chemists that we spoke to
and there in the UK so you know you take
that sample for what what you will that
wasn't the set of services that they
were asking for right I mean they were
asking for
you know I this data so that when I go
to write my article I can find it that
was really the set of services that they
were that they were looking for I don't
doubt that that that's not generalizable
but I just want to be clear that that's
what that's what we thought yeah are we
done okay sorry okay I'm delighted to
see so much interest in discussion and I
just wanted to thank Roger for his
presentation this morning
you